rick carlisle who's the number-one X's
and O's guy I read a book where he
recently said like X's and O's is 10% of
being a pro head coach yeah and my
problem is Rick Carlos Carlos said about
is about himself my problem is I don't
know how to relate to these guys as well
and that's the most important part of
the job so a Phil he got the X's and O's
and then the other 90% dude brilliant
[ __ ] brilliant this guy could be a
leader of a country you know dude
100% great leadership and you know what
I realized I'm sitting there I'm like
why the [ __ ] did Jordan listen to this
[ __ ] like yes Jordan got along
with Doug cuz they sup both had the same
fire and I think Jordan mired the Doug
just kinda like said whatever happened
but he also kissed Jordans ass and then
you know Jordan was having this
incredible success under Doug so you're
definitely gonna relate some of that to
him you know what I was really telling
about their relationship what'd he call
him what what he called Doug Collins I
don't know dougie if that's a coach to
me that you really respect as a coach
you're not giving her a nickname that's
a peer it was one of the sniffers yeah
it was another sniffer even he wasn't a
philosopher oh you're not above me if
you're Doug it was a sniffer then what
was the play at the end of the game is
something like that just get the ball to
George didn't [ __ ] out the way that was
the play every play right right yeah
which is cool but Phil had this Phil had
this different energy right and Jordan
didn't even like Phil when he came in
yeah but I was like why the [ __ ] did he
end up listening to him yes don't get me
wrong
Phil knows how to get in your head with
the Zen but what did Phil have the
Jordan didn't jewelry oh we got to with
the Knicks and one with that CBA team
say what it is it doesn't matter I did
not know that we didn't know that he
played for the Albany there was a CBA
team they didn't coached
so he got to it the mix yeah right and
then he coached a team in the CBA and he
got one with them so when he's telling
Jordan this what you gotta do I'm not
telling you this as someone who has as
many rings as you which is zero I'm
telling you someone who's done it as a
player and as a coach yeah I know some
[ __ ] [ __ ] it do you want these
is this what you cuz I know how to get
these you don't if you did you'd have
them now
in the fact that he coached in Puerto
Rico and had to deal like the crazy [ __ ]
language barrier craziness going on this
relationship would kill the chickens the
Puerto Ricans cut no chickens kill each
other you cut the chicken that snare
it's the [ __ ] mayor doing it and it
was not energy when the conquistadors
came yes yes just look walk over me halt
it's not happening again anymore it's a
foul nuts
yes that's all the punishment was you
can't come to games anymore for the rest
of the season home games home games I'm
assuming you're not traveling for the
rest of this year just sit it out you
almost killed somebody
yeah that's crazy that's great it was
but you know was interesting about the
MJ thing there was a tipping point with
trusting Phil okay and it was the finals
against the Lakers in the closeout game
remember when we talked about finding
Paxson Phil told him like John is open
every time give him the ball he said
who's open who's all know yeah and this
is such a genius thing you let someone
come up with the conclusion themselves
you're right
and now you're not telling them what to
do and MJ's a guy you don't tell what to
do now you mention it I'll leave the
same my pops used to go to Ollie's camp
a lot and he said Ollie's coach oh my
god why am I forgetting all the [ __ ] his
coach's done being Angelo Dundee Angelo
would never tell Ollie what to do he'd
ask Ollie hey what should we do now late
we could work on some abs that's a good
idea let's work with a vet right now he
knows that we got to work on naps but he
knows you don't tell mehat leaders do
they ask yeah you Muhammad Ali's gonna
do the work yeah George is gonna do the
work yeah you got to motivate them to
work
[Applause]